みんな自転車に乗りだけだったことはないかい
やっぱ皆さん今子供の頃は自転車に乗ってのしてっ
子供の人もいるでしょ一端霊社ってこうなんか
このばするかのエキサイティング
ずれ書で後年もう走り回ってジャンプと過去いろんなテクニカルな今洗馬駅たい丁寧な
左右の
チャリー走りたいとかいいと思うよけどね現実はそんな甘くない
[音楽]
ってで今日はねか自転車で公益製品に走りたいという人ためのようなスペシャル後よ
紹介します敗れを知っている人いると思うんですけどチャリ走っていうゲームがあるん
ですよ僕がここ12年生の時からあってすごい簡単になっているんですよ
あの時はなかなかパパッと携帯のアプリてすごいシンプルだったんですけど
おっす
ママでもねその者リーダーはパワーアップして出てさらにパワーアップしてた
キャリイそうでなく普通って言ってたって高校だろチャリ走やってるわけだね
まずそこらへんのね皆にねボケがぁにチャリ走で負けちゃいけないと思うんで
今日は俺の実力を披露して皆に悔しい想いよねさせようと思います
では行こうねマジで僕はもう初心者じゃないから結構
パティでこんな感じになっておりますあぁ懐かしいアプリ
ゲットっていうサイトからやってたんだよねその
パカパカ携帯の時はいろいろあるんですよ galaxy tour って言う
now loading って言う
こういういろんなステージができるところもありますや床のグランプリっていうあの
ひたすらひたすら進んでいく感じのやつあとはムーヴせるステージ相手のショップ
それぞれデラックス色々あるんですけど今日はねなんかこーねこーコースの南葛レス
横部せずにね
まあ僕の猫の音腕っぷしよねもう見せればそれでいいと思ってるんで
グランプリをやります
ああああああ
始めたと今23位0メールで b なんで一位は誰だ
3083メートルかよし1回目で行くから
かましたるでー
音量上げる
まじまじ見たらマジ見てろ
おおなんかゆっくりのステージですね
まぁこれぐらいなぁ全然良いですよ
チャリ走はねあのジャンプするときは画面をタッチすればいいだけです
[音楽]
ごめんちょっと静かになるねぇ
いやーこれぐらいあんステイずはも全然ユスよ
おいジャンプ
ほい
パワーぴょんぴょん
全然余裕だ
[音楽]
本当によりまずでちょっと3000メートルくらい流れる
3000メートルぐらいのができるんであれ
行くぞ
これを連れから
余裕
これは当たったら死にそうな色をしてますね
たぶねー
やはり超動く床がう
いやもうねじゃあもうヌクヌクッ
山ややばいやばいや迷っ
本当にちょっとみんなに自慢したいんだ
岩瀬いいぞ天才だ俺 is は富豪と小ロット4霜月さんのいきます
はぁ
[音楽]
やっぱりこれは持ってる男なんだよねー
まあチャリ走普通のは要するに今ぞのゲームなんですよ今増
いかに年パジ電車を愛してる書く
あぶねーやっぱりいかにね自転車を愛してるかって言うとかね
まあこのゲームのポイントになってくるねー
まぁ結局年気合があるやつがいいスコアを出せるゲームなんですよ
僕みたよねこういう音
今
バー
ジャイアントじゃないよ1時まできました
いわゆるでちょっとちょっとびっくりしたっしょこいつただものじゃないとか思った
でしょ
まあ号機が本気出せばでもう一問目取るからいーくんでね
大江さんわぁああ落ちる for so
そう上様ここには抑えきれないああこういう
さっきのれを超えろとりあえずさっきの量を超えろ
いやなおす
というさっきの俺を超えたいさっきの俺を超えたよ
はあああああ
王道 rpg
やべぇマジかここまでか僕だ西川4353でした
もう大津行けたんだけどなんてやっ自転車壊れるもんなんでね
そういうところで高忠実に再現しているんでやっぱり電車は無限にあるわけじゃないん
でなくできる台数は決まっているわけです
これはまた時間方でも拝復するんで僕の場合は残り5分50秒くらいかそれぐらいたっ
たらまた
できますまあね午前も越えられないような気
2つにはね僕の5000超えてからねこうなんか色々お礼人は言って来てください
まぁ僕も近いうちに1万出すんで是非チャリ走をやってみてください本当に多分
ハマります北高校の時部活とこれしかしてなかったんでじゃあ